i don't know man watching you in there
like when it was coming i think it was
like the fourth round i think you walked
up to the korean zombie and you're like
are you sure you want to yeah that was
the most fire [ __ ] ever dude it kind of
looked in your face when you were like i
mean the third it looked really like you
were like somebody's got to stop this
yeah that's exactly what it was so
that's exactly what you heard because i
think it is doing the rounds where
people are saying what i said i did say
something i remember looking at i'm like
telling the ref i'm like he's done man
like yeah because i could i can tell by
looking at uh people when they're
defeated right and they're even looking
for a way out you just see their eyes
yeah they're like yeah warriors aren't
going to sit there and i'm done put
their hand up and let the world know
that i'm done yeah but they're going to
you know wherever they're like
pretending they can't see which sort
happened with the ortega fight as well
oh i saw that yeah so little things like
you know uh there was a moment in that
ortega fight where he literally said i
can't see it yeah exactly you don't tell
a you don't tell a ref that
because if you're talking about that
they've got a subject
they're gonna stop that so uh you know
for you to say that you are already
accepting that they're going to stop it
you've got to mean or you're you're
accepting that it's over and if they
stop it whatever you wouldn't tell them
that put it this way if i was in that
position
i am poker face 100 all the way and
you're not going to know but these are
the reasons i was getting i was like man
he's done yeah and you know he was never
going to give up and like he even
stumbled to the center yeah and then
it's starting i'm like i literally put
my hands down i go
you really want to keep doing this like
you know what i mean he's like he
probably didn't understand me
really i don't think he understood me
but he's just like oh yeah yeah yeah and
then like i'm like are you sure he's
like yeah yeah but even if he did
understand me he probably would have
been the same thing he's not going to
say i'm done he's not going to tell me
that yeah but i'm like all right but
then it was like a couple of seconds
after that i finished do fighters ever
have a safe word
hey do that fighters don't ever have a
safe word with their sex brothers
no no i mean
no i'm saying with their coaches like
you're in the corner and you say
something like oh yeah [ __ ]
watermelon and that means like yo i
can't go on okay
well that's a problem right that's what
i think is a big problem right now is uh
there's that that sort of uh you know
the relationship with the coach and the
the student where
the coach probably wants to stop it but
then they're like he's probably gonna be
that angry at me if i stop it like you
know at the end of the day that
shouldn't matter yeah safety for you
know safety first but yeah that's a
tricky one where they i feel like uh
they do need to have these conversations
yeah i don't know if watermelon's gonna
be a secret word but i mean well now
everybody's gonna know
you're just screaming pumpkin in the
corner and people like what the [ __ ] is
that
at least have that conversation right
yeah so if i if i don't look like i'm
looking for an answer and
things isn't going my way and i'm just
[ __ ] getting punched in the face yeah
um
you know maybe you know we're going to
do this this is going to be what we do
i'm going to give you one more chance
and we're going to do something if
they're filming you in the corner and
you know you got cameras on you yeah and
the coach is like i'm going to stop the
fight you can't be like yes please yeah
yeah i think you're right yeah you have
to say no yeah you have to fight they
always will yeah everybody's looking
that was the same with the ortega one a
lot like i said there oh he was looking
for a way out and i don't mean that any
disrespect no no i mean it was just it
was there exactly it was a brilliant to
come back and all that and for him to
think about it being in that mental
state right well you're done yeah i'm
done i'm cooked that's it i want them to
stop this then they don't give you that
out and then you have to go back in
there and then just be like oh [ __ ] it
let's just keep going then and then just
try and turn it back around which you've
got to give him credit for so i mean
dude that choke i just i've watched that
choke maybe like 40 times i still don't
know how you got out of the choke and i
want you to tell me but before you tell
me my suspicion is somehow you lasted
long enough where he got tired
is that right yeah yeah that's pretty
much it
obviously those techniques to
to lit like at least make space
what does it lean into well like i was
obviously pulling on his arm i was
pushing on his hips to you know get his
hips high and to change the angle on the
neck and uh
yeah obviously trying to turn the the
chin in and things like that just enough
and the lights were dimming that's
that's uh something like that's what
i've been like how i explained right
literally the lights were demons quite
couldn't hear a thing no i'm like oh
[ __ ] this can't be here right like i was
uh thinking this belt not coming over my
family like this can't be [ __ ] it and
uh then i just kept doing what i was
doing even though it wasn't working at
the start but i was just yeah i'm
persistent i'm a stubborn [ __ ] so i'm
like going [ __ ] that i'm gonna keep
going and then uh just slowly the lights
started coming i'm like he's gonna gas
out his arms will gas out before i
before i go to sleep and then i just
felt it i'm like oh yeah i'm going to
[ __ ] get you now that's what i mean
that's a literally what i was thinking
once i get out of here i'm going to make
you pay because he's going to be [ __ ]
exhausted 100 and i could already feel
it you know what i mean and then even
the scrambles he was going for other
chokes on i knew i'd get up and i'm like
on he's going to be drained now i've got
to better pour it on and that's exactly
what i did
you